ciao ho di nuovo episodio in cui andiamo
a vedere delle illusioni ottiche
pazzesche quindi come sempre mettetevi
comodi palatino e pop corn
lasciate un bel light su questo video mi
raccomando anche se volete vedere altri
video di illusioni ottiche cose
particolari fatemi sapere nei commenti
cosa vorreste vedere lasciate un bel
like e ora siete pronti
iniziamo subito che i ragazzi prima
illusione ottica
dobbiamo fissare lo schermo in cui c'è
l'illusione ottica che sarei non
distogliere lo sguardo dopodichè
dobbiamo distogliere lo sguardo e
guardare la vostra camera il vostro foto
ovunque voi siate però non dovete
distogliere lo sguardo mentre la
guardiamo sente pronti via e figo
è il latitante ma mi addormento tipo mi
raccomando non di poterlo scordo che
sembra che stia cambiando si sta
cambiando
[Musica]
non esente
mi raccomando non mi studiate lo sguardo
e sto guardando al centro proprio non
potete spaccio di bianco con i super
ricchi di 70
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi raccomando continuate a guardare
[Musica]
oddio ma questa bellissima società anche
che dietro al ma è un conoscitore io
[Musica]
[Applauso]
resto sempre tipo aiuta questa in
tribuna tra con noi di stagione lo
guarda
oddio come vi sentite come lo faccia
premi con me tra poco possiamo guardare
guardarci intorno
[Musica]
ok guardatevi intorno a cosa mi vedo
tutto che si rimpicciolisce ovunque mi
sposto però le cose che si
rimpiccioliscono tipo risucchiate ok ora
questo è bastato del tutto perfetto
vogliono sapere nei commenti che cosa
avete visto se ha funzionato se non ha
funzionato che cosa avete visto dopo e
porteremo relativa ok ora dobbiamo
fissare il pallino bianco quindi fissa
che il pallino bianco e seguitelo quindi
pallino bianco al centro poi come fa
mosca rilassante mi addormento tipo
perché mi sto tenendo svegli io con la
mia voce parte fissando pallino bianco
non distogliere lo sguardo
[Musica]
ok ragazzi quasi finito proprio possiamo
guardarci intorno
[Musica]
guardatevi intorno ott io vedo ancora il
vortice tipo che figo vengono quel
vortice
oddio voi cosa vedete scrivete nei
commenti cosa avete visto con questa
seconda eruzione
ora sta tradendo così passato del tutto
ok prossimo dobbiamo guardare lo stesso
al centro questa ex ok egizia che sembra
che le imposte dalle persone a paliano
distorte si aggira come possibile sembra
non si dimostri anche noi ha dei figli
di mostri dovete guardare sempre al
tempo
ormai dice credito salvarsi farmi
processare queste immagini in una
frazione di tipo molto stretta prossimo
ok quanti sono 16 pallini neri e disse
che sicuramente non riuscire non
riuscirete vederli tutti allo stesso
tempo molti è vero come spostino sguardo
appaiono quelli neri però poi scompaiono
gli altri quelli del centro scompaiono e
che spostate lo sguardo né appaiono
altri fatemi sapere se anche per voi è
così
[Musica]
questo con un filo forte ma che figo ma
nessuno ricorda questo tra pietro sembra
che si stia guardando ma secondo
nicoletti sposti ok prossima che numero
vedete dentro questa immagine io vedo
oddio mi sembra di vedere un 46 e un 7
prossimo truffa oddio poiché lo vedete
io vedo un 46 è un setter vediamo qual è
il numero che c'è dentro
[Musica]
e meno male poiché non mi avete messo
ora vedo mi5 e un sei mai riuscito a
vederlo si fanno male non sono sempre o
daltonica vedo in due e 1
fatemi sapere se stato eletto per
riuscito che sono riuscito a vedere in
credute ingrandire il video 12 e 15
[Musica]
simeri mare
ottimo per piccole 708 forse sì vero
male questo è il test per l'alto
omicidio e non sette ma cosa vedete nel
male per i colori
io vedo in 16
[Applauso]
[Musica]
motivo per sé difficile decidere
qualcosa è difficilissimo questo memoria
continuo di 080 forse lo 0 0 0 non si
capisce o meno male 0 0
[Applauso]
penso una t secondo voi tra sette in
vetta non a s difficile anche questo si
era net
una festa ha perso punti
[Musica]
un cuore forse si è normale oddio non lo
vedo
hanno forse una freccia chiamava quella
parte che uscisse come del resto si meno
male no praticamente niente
per te qualcosa della croce voglio
provare a farlo perché sono tutte le
nostre news
[Musica]
c'è da dire che hanno scelto dalle foto
bruttissime di questi attori foreste
franco pezzo
[Musica]
voi come ripetente
ok ragazzi queste erano le ventenni
ottiche per oggi mi sta girando la testa
non capisco perchè penso per quella
illusione musica dall'inizio sul retro
notizia te
oh mio dio cosa mi sta bene se volete
vederne altre mi raccomando lasciato un
bel laiche e vi lascio raffa 4 catherine
hsu potete cliccare per vedere i
prossimi video cliccate su quella che
prevendite e buona visione